Speaker 1: Let's go next to Cody from San Diego.
Cody, I'm going to be in San Diego this weekend.
In fact, how how's the weather looking?
Speaker 4:
Hey, David, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: I can hear you, Cody.
Speaker 4: It's it's just got done raining down
here, but it's it's looking pretty good today.
Speaker 2: All right.
Speaker 1: Good. Well, yeah,
I'm hoping to have a nice, nice sunny weekend.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Speaker 4: My question was first one, I would
just I keep hearing like all these people on the
I guess I mean, obviously on the right,
Speaker 2: but a lot of people on
Speaker 4: the left have like. A problem
with AOC and her policies and just,
I guess, her personality and everything, I
was just wondering what your opinion was and.
What you feel about her, what you what you think
about her, I generally tend to agree with her and
like a lot of what she does.
Speaker 2: So yeah, I
Speaker 1: think I think AOC is extremely skilled
politically in terms of her ability to communicate
in terms of her ability to participate in
congressional hearings and question people.
I think she gets a lot of issues right. As I've
said before, I think she lacks some knowledge when
it comes to certain economic ideas and on some
foreign policy stuff, but she's still relatively
new. We would expect anybody to lack knowledge in
some areas. It's not like a big deal, you know,
it's not like a big attack on AOC. So I think she
Speaker 2: has major
Speaker 1: potential to be a huge player for
decades in the progressive movement if she wants
to. And at the same time, she may not want to. She
may want to do this for a little bit and then do
something something completely different. So I
think in terms of thinking about the future of
the progressive movement, we don't want to put all
our eggs in any one basket, if that makes sense.
Speaker 4: Yeah, it does. Just a real I guess
my my other question would be I heard a lot.
I guess it was in the past there was an article
that came out and destiny talked about it a little
bit that people were talking about how how much
voter suppression actually affects elections. So
I I recognize that like it's
probably kind of a combination of
like voter suppression and redistricting tactics
that kind of cumulative affect elections. But
in your opinion, realistically, how
Speaker 2: much how much do you think like
Speaker 4: voter suppression tactics, actually?
Speaker 1: Say again, this is such a hard thing
to answer, because the first thing is which
elections right? Which elections are we talking
about a presidential race? Are we talking
about congressional districts for the House
of Representatives? I'm not actually. I'm not
asking you to give me the answers. I'm just
saying in order to really answer the question, we
first need to define that. Then there are aspects
of this that can be measured and aspects that are
tougher to measure. So for example, if someone
Speaker 2: is rejected
Speaker 1: from voting because of a specific
rule, we could say, Wow, that's definitely someone
whose vote was affected by voter suppression.
But if there are people
Speaker 2: who, because of
Speaker 1: their awareness of voting, has been
limited in this way or voting places or whatever
the case may be, say I'm not even going to
Speaker 2: look at voting this year.
Speaker 1: That's sort of like soft voter
suppression. And I don't really I don't
Speaker 2: trust that we can
Speaker 1: accurately quantify that in
any real way. So my answer is
Speaker 2: in in sum
Speaker 1: total, there is no doubt that voter
suppression tactics combined with gerrymandering
have an effect. How many races are won or
lost on that basis? It's a very difficult
question to answer, but here's a really important
thing. The fact that it's a difficult question
to answer doesn't mean that we should fall
for well, then it must be having no effect.
That would be fallacious. Took to go to that.
Speaker 4: Yeah, I tend to agree. Well, that's the
questions I have. Thank you so much for answering.
Speaker 1: Thank you for
calling. Great to great
Speaker 2: to hear from you.